-Anthony,
good to see you, buddy.
Here's how this --
-What's up, man?
-Here's how it's gonna work.
I'm gonna ask you
for some silly words --
nouns, verbs, adjectives,
things like that.
As we do that, they'll be
written into our prompter
and sent over and bleep-blorped
into where you are.
And then --
well, since it's Halloween,
we're gonna tell a scary
Mad Libs story at the end
using those words, basically.
You cool with that?
-I like it.
-All right. Here we go.
All right. Here we go.
Ready?
Give me an adjective.
-Dirty.
-Hmm.
Give me a type of relative.
-Uh...
Step-uncle.
[ Laughter ]
You got to watch
those step-uncles, man.
-I mean, come on.
Step-uncle is the --
That's -- I want to see
that movie already.
[ Laughter ]
A country.
-Uh...
Czech Republic.
-Type of profession.
-Uh...
Garbage man.
-Yeah.
A food that you'd find
at a carnival.
-Uh...Ooh!
A New Orleans carnival --
pig lips.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, man.
[ Laughter continues ]
That is --
Body part.
-Belly button.
-Give me a number.
-23.
-Give me another adjective.
-Uh...
Funktified.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
Plural type of animal.
-Uh...
Fish.
Fishes.
-What would you scream
riding a roller coaster?
-Uh...
"Help me, Mama!"
Yeah.
-"Help me, Mama."
[ Both laugh ]
A verb ending in I-N-G.
-Running.
-Keep it PG.
-Chain restaurant.
-Ooh.
Church's.
-Come on, man.
-Wow.
Church's.
-[ Laughing ]
-Amount of time.
-350 seconds.
A noise you'd make
lifting heavy weights.
Oh, that's kind of
a loaded question there.
-A grunt.
Unh!
-Okay.
Name a celebrity.
-David Hasselhoff.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-I love that guy.
-Verb ending in I-N-G.
-Spelunking.
[ Laughter ]
Things you'd shout if you found
a raccoon in your house.
-Uh...
Kill him!
[ Light laughter ]
Tasty!
-Uh, "tasty" I'm gonna use.
-I'm telling you.
-Item that you had
in your teenage bedroom.
-A refrigerator.
-Word?
-You had a fridge
in your teenage bedroom?
-I had a fridge and a hot plate.
I used to cook up whole meals.
-A fridge and a hot--
Fridge is great.
All right.
Finally, a plural body part.
-Foots.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. We filled out the words
for our story.
Gosh, you're perfect for this.
All right.
Ready to perform this?
We're gonna do it together.
You ready?
-Let's do it.
-Let's go.
[ Wind howling, owl hooting ]
-Is that you?
-Where you at?
-Let me tell you something.
It was a dark
and dirty night when a --
-Yes.
-When a teenager
and his step-uncle
were driving through the woods
of the Czech Republic.
-Wait.
The car radio was broadcasting
warnings of an escaped
garbage man called Mr. Pig Lips.
[ Laughter ]
[ Wolf howling ]
[ Both laugh ]
[ Laughter continues ]
That's the best!
-It is!
[ Laughter continues ]
It gets better.
It gets better. Wait.
[ Both laugh ]
He was nicknamed that
because pig lips
replaced his belly button.
[ Thunder crashes ]
[ Laughter ]
-Just then, 23 funktified fishes
ran across their path.
[ Cat screeches ]
The teenager screeched
on his brakes and shouted,
"Help me, Mama!"
[ Owl hooting ]
-The car's engine suddenly died.
So the teenager's step-uncle
got out
and started running to the
nearest Church's for help.
[ Laughing ]
-After what seemed
like 350 seconds,
the teenagers began hearing
a faint noise
outside the car window.
Unh!
It started getting louder.
Unhhh!
And louder.
Unh-unh-unhhh!!
[ Creepy organ music plays ]
-In the distance,
the teenagers spotted
a shadowy figure
walking towards his car.
As it got closer,
he saw it was...
David Hasselhoff spelunking!
[ Woman screams ]
-"Tasty!" the teenager screamed,
grabbing a refrigerator
and a hot plate
from his glove compartment.
-He rubbed
his foots and looked again.
[ Laughter ]
But now no one was there.
The only thing he saw
on the ground was a pile...
of pig lips!
[ Laughter ]
[ Wolf howling ]
-Some say if you drive
through the woods
of the Czech Republic at night.
-Of the Czech Republic at night.
-You can still see
David Hasselhoff spelunking.
[ Thunder crashes ]
-And scene!
Oh, gosh.
♪♪
[ Laughing ]
He left, he left.
-I'm done!
[ Both laugh ]
-That's all
for "Mad Lib Theater."